Because a, it's not your land
be, you mentioned Europe.
Well you can tell me that.
Please don't say that.
When it comes to the Israeli
Palestinian conflict,
I think I'm mostly emotionally sad.
I think it's not fair that you
know a country that is peaceful.
Being in a situation where
we have to be threatened.
Being an Arab girl,
living inside of the Israeli state,
it's pretty hard for me
to find exactly who I am.
What of the Palestinians who still live
under occupation. So we have no power.
I believe that every person,
Jew, Christian, Muslim,
should be full equal citizens
under Israeli software.
We need just to end this
conflict between us.
It's because we don't need the other
generations to live the life that we live
in.
Continue to do what we did until now.
It's probably going to stay and
we need to do something else.
My name's Hannah, Ziad. I'm 24 years
old and I'm an area being utuber.
My name is [inaudible].
I'm 25 years old and I'm
a Jewish Israeli Zionist.
My name is [inaudible].
I'm from netlists 25 years old.
Studied public relations
and communications.
My name is [inaudible].
I'm from a small town called [inaudible]
right outside of Jerusalem and I'm 24
years old.
My name is Arab domain, how many? 24
years old. And I'm from Jerusalem.
My name is Ron [inaudible].
I'm 34 years old and I work as a deputy
director of a think tank that deals with
law and economics.
Firstly
because of this.
Okay.
Okay. My father was murdered
by two IDF soldiers.
Um, it hit us hard,
especially for my family.
We're only girls and and inside of
the Arabic nation that's really hard.
My friend when I was 10
years old is we get a sniper,
a should it her, uh, in her head.
So that was really hard for us.
No, I grew up during the second
intifada, the carry a list with
me of
all my friends who were
murdered in terror attacks.
So I have a list of 27 people.
They were actually very close to me
in Israel. We have on Memorial Day.
So I have always a dilemma
which grave to go to.
The 16th of January,
2007 Israeli soldier shutting
killed my sister there.
She was 10 years old,
front of Ferris called and I was 13.
We were six kids in the house.
After that way we can,
okay.
All of the people that I
know have lost someone, um,
to the warrant in some way.
And I think like grief is
such a universal emotion.
Like I'm, I really, I want to hog it.
I serve in the IDF.
I still serve in the army reserves combat.
I was very competent. The second
Intifada, and I feel your grief and I,
I understand it,
but I have to say that I've,
I never got an order to shoot someone.
Uh,
the origin was only to shoot if someone
is a threat to your life or a third to
someone else's lives.
I also served in the IDF and they really
do just teach us to defend ourselves.
If we're not defending ourselves and
we do kill someone, we go to jail.
That's not true.
I can't tell you something.
The soldier that killed my sister,
he didn't spend one day in there.
Neither did my father,
both of them that murder him
did not stay in one day in jail.
I haven't we a Tuesdays
pollution as possible.
Okay. I think that Tinian they will
not stop saying that. We we want,
we want a country.
So in the end,
if we got to the point that we
have our state and they have,
they state so no problem.
Okay.
This is going to be better for
us to live all of us together,
which has no state like Palestinian,
no state like Israeli only together and
having fits together like there is no
walls and there is no checkpoints
which has happened right now
I'm with you. One state, Andrew,
Israel's sovereignty and everyone's
full equal citizen. Alrighty. Okay.
But Andrew Israeli sovereignty because
right now I [inaudible] he's got a
problem. Why should it be on one?
Why should one religion control?
Why can't that region, it's a
nationality. It's my nationality. So if
Justinian the Palestinian, they control
it. You can't live under it. No,
because it's not going to because hey,
it's not your land be,
you mentioned your slip.
You can tell me please.
100% that's then used to
meant one question. Yes.
These Ansari, you are a grand four
grand grandfather. You know where he is.
Yes. Winning is to give me how many, how
many grades do you want me to call? Seven.
Three, four, seven. Before I knew it.
Yes. Seven before isn't hungry and hungry.
Nine before he isn't Palestine.
Don't tell me it's not more than that.
I'm saying it's not your land.
It's our land and will be
like,
how do you determine this is our land
and it's not their land based on what
history? International law.
Interest. So Verdi. Yes.
How about empathy?
I have empathy.
I'm just not willing to live to give
up on my identity and what I believe is
mine.
I'm afraid of the other side.
When I say that I'm afraid.
What I basically mean is I'm afraid of
going into Gaza because I knew that if I
will go into Gaza, I might get
shot. Someone might kill me.
I think I hesitated a little bit.
I don't think I'm afraid of
the people on the other side.
I think I'm afraid of the gap and
sort of almost equally afraid of like,
you know that side taking all of their
responsibility for what is happening or
this side taking all of the
responsibility for what is happening,
which is obviously not working
well that's fair enough.
I don't believe that all Palestinians
are terrorists cause that doesn't make
sense.
But I do believe that who is in charge,
they are leading the Palestinians to,
you know, hating us and in, in, in,
in a way that, you know,
eight is really unfair.
I'm against against what you saying they
are lot days lab because Islam didn't,
didn't say kill killing people or
having your blood don't belong that
cool Muslims, the radical Muslim
said come and do these things.
What do you have to say?
They're not part of us.
We never accept them as Muslims
because they're teaching hate.
And in a way I accepted what you just
said about there's a big problem with our
government. They don't know how to
talk to each other. And in my idea,
I really think the people are the ones
that I should be talking to each other.
I agree. And I have to say also don't
think there's an issue with Muslims,
but I disagree with you about the
fact that it's about plans there.
There's several peace talks.
They were offered 97% of the land,
98 would have done it.
They disagree.
After deciding with the land,
they came and they built more settlements.
What's wrong?
What's wrong with Jews living in Judea?
That's not the problem.
The problem is,
is that we actually talked about
this land being for these people.
And in the end when we see Israelis coming
in and actually building houses that
showing us we. Dot. You
guys don't want peace.
I shrunk.
I serve in the IDF. So first of
all, I trust myself and my officers.
I do think that a lot of the
information I'm getting is not accurate,
which is why I tried to it
with different, uh, sources.
And I also start to see it
from, from people, what they,
what they think would they feel
okay?
I don't trust everything. I
see on the news, that's for
sure. I do believe, again,
there are two sides to every single story,
but I do see things that are
happening. For instance, you know,
things like the rockets that are
striking or the stabs that are happening,
those things I do trust because I can
see that they're happening and they're
just unfair.
Like I see the,
the narrative being written.
I was like,
I watch TV.
I know how important and how powerful
language is and how it can create um,
reality and like I can,
I can see it.
I like this is really
dangerous on both sides.
It's really dangerous.
Overseas media that I see,
they're always against Israel for things
that are not necessarily our fault.
I find it very funny because we look
at it as in start saying that they're
really with Israel, which is
funny. I find it kind of funny,
but no,
I seriously do find the information that
we're getting has more as an agenda to
it from both sides.
I don't believe in social media.
Like from the Israeli side,
I'm going to support Israel
and the Palestinian side
get a support. Palestinians.
People are going to be very confused and
I'm going to be very confused about the
reality
smooth flavor date.
The question was the sources.
So it doesn't have to be just social
media and I'm going to be poor.
It's like this.
Like I also trust the reports that the
Israel's six to security forces, uh,
publish,
but they are doing their ideas
about the reality in the situation,
but their ideas, how do they
are a seed, his situation,
it's not really what happened.
Political leaders on my
side to many compromises
per piece.
If we continue to do
what we did until now,
it's going to continue as it was now.
And I don't see it getting better.
Our leaders should have our lives and
and the best for us in their minds.
And so it's not compromising
like pieces never compromising
the Palestinian bulletin. They, the,
they one a piece for they
selves and for the people,
but they have no power because the power,
it's not in they hand. It's the end,
the other side.
Okay.
I would like for us to compromise only
if you will be able to compromise.
It doesn't make sense that
every time that we have a war,
it's always started by your side. The
other year, a day I just heard about,
you know, over 1,800 acres
of crops had been burned by,
you know, Hamas who have been sending
it over to Israel instead of, you know,
all that money in order to ruin us.
Why don't they spend it on taking
care of uh, Palestine? I talk,
just wait just one second.
You're talking about Hamas.
You have talking about Gaza.
It's so far from us.
We don't know what's going over there.
We don't know if you can ask me about
the West Bank. I'm can, I'm going to ask.
I'll answer.
I think you as well,
but here's the way I see it.
When you're talking about compromise,
Hamas' Charter says murder. Did she?
Wherever they are in the PA did.
There's a golden bear and hold on,
hold on, hold on. But the PA, the PA,
let me finish it, but it's in the
authority that are the moderates.
They're saying it's a death sentence.
If you sell your house,
did you are there are racist
people of Israel of course,
are the racist people
everywhere in the world. Yes.
But we condemn people who are acting
violently and the other side glorifies
violence is justified.
Ooh,
I don't know.
If you're going to attack Israel,
then Israel is given to defend themselves
and that means when it comes to
certain things, maybe not
you specifically, but again,
to the radical Muslims, we
have to, because if we don't,
then there's not going to be
a state of Israel anymore.
I don't think it's a matter of um,
Israeli Arabs or Jewish. As Christians.
Sometimes we laugh.
You have to use violence.
I hope it will be close
to zero as possible,
but if I see someone about
to murder someone else,
I think it's okay for me to
use violence to stop that.
I think violence is not
allowed for a political goal.
I think that's a bad
place to use violence.
I prefer talking and having a discourse.
Okay. I didn't grow up with a, with
a lot of violence with zero violence,
but what I went to say
the same as you said,
who comes to my house to broke
the door to take my father.
Of course I will live in school myself,
so it's called a violence.
But I want a difference for myself first.
Well,
I am against violence 100% it's a freaking
circle is going to keep on happening
over and over again for me.
If you're going to react for
the violence with violence.
So here we go.
We're having like the same problems,
the same generation who's a raise with
hatred and violence and love blood,
which is not accepted.
Is it important?
I think that Israel needs to be our
homeland because if we won't have a
homeland, no one else is going
to accept us anywhere else.
Especially because there's a lot
of racism and antisemitism as well.
So if we're not going to be here,
where are we going to go?
Okay. For me as a Muslim, the
Holy Land. It's why it's so,
first of all, because I was born here,
I have no place at another place.
Every single person around the word had
the right to live in the plate that they
were born.
And that the right for Palestinians
also for if we're going to talk about
refugees also, they have the right
to come back here, did their labs,
did their homes and uh,
have their places.
The fact that we came back to our homeland
and that we do have a country in a
government here for me,
like it does feel like a miracle.
But I also think that the fact that
we do have the power now gives us more
responsibility.
Um,
and that we can't just base it on the
fact that it's our homeland and not hear
other voices saying we feel
the same about the same place.
My place.
Okay
all the time requested me if he's
more dialogue, more force, more. Um,
conversation is more social media. I
always ask myself, what is the best thing?
I tend to believe that the best
thing is um, human interaction.
A lot of times I take a step
back from like the political,
the political argument about the conflict
and all of that just because I feel
like I'm worthy and that
I don't know enough.
So it my way, I've always known
what I, what I am in this conflict.
I always knew I wanted to fight for peace.
That's all I knew.
And that's all I will ever know.
I never was in the idea of this
conflict until my father passed away.
And then I had to think for myself.
I always was asking my
father why he was born
and his answer not to kill,
to live,
to be in life. And when
my sister, she got killed,
I went back to him to tell him.
He told me that he was born to live.
No. Okay. But my sister,
she was born to die.
They are a Palestinian,
they didn't kill 6 million Israelis.
And the Israelis is 10
[inaudible] 6 million Palestinian.
There is a Germanian embassy in Tel
Aviv and there isn't a German Israelis
empathy and Germania.
So
it's a big hole.
It's always gives me a hug.
When I'm looking at this and
thinking a little bit about this,
I'm going to say I think it's,
it's, it's nice slogans. They just,
I don't think that's the case.
Israel has a peace treaty with Egypt
because Egypt was willing to have peace
with Israel.
Israel has a peace treaty with Jordan
because the Jordanians were willing to
have a pastry with,
with Israel.
Altaf run one to one. It's, it's different
how the way you think and the green,
which is exactly why I don't believe in a,
in a peace between the two sides
because in my understanding of reality,
the whole concept of Palestinian
nationality because you don't accept
Palestinians except human beings.
I'm saying that the whole
concept of destination reality
is one goal and that is
the violation of Israel. Um, when
Jordan took over Judea and Samaria,
when Egypt took over the Gaza
and no one asks for a post,
you were combining every one. You're
combining everyone into one ideology,
which is not right. Why? What do you mean?
You're saying because they're
saying that they're Palestinians.
This is what they want,
which is not true. I, I take it back and
governments the Palestinian Authority.
Okay. I'm not saying I agree. It's, it's
different. I, I'm, I want to say, okay.
We'll just, I don't refer to
the Arabs and Dan's scenarios.
[inaudible] they're referred to in this
scenario. If we were going to live long,
long gauge or [inaudible] we gonna see,
we're gonna see each other.
We, we're going to,
we're going to have it.
You can have it. No, no. I'm talking
about peace. We're going to have it.
Yeah.
Share with everyone.
Hello.
Hey guys.
I'm Johnny. I'm a dog. I think that
there's on top of some
passion fruit juice,
which gives the kick.
So how was the experience?
For me, it was perfect.
It was good.
It was a good meeting.
It was topsy turvy. It was
upside down if the Kenyan, yeah,
like I say that because like you don't
know who's was in front of you and you
don't know their ideas. Do your
ideology, what they think about you.
I think we did come to some sort of an
agreement that we both do one piece,
security freedom and prosperity.
You were talking about legal piece.
I don't want a piece of paper and it
says peace. I want to live in peace.
I don't want a piece of paper
says we have a peace treaty
but we don't agree because I don't believe
in a Palestinian state and you think
you should have like a two state
solution so we don't agree and it's,
so let's say we wanted a one state
solution Israel with everyone equal I'm,
I'm fine with it. Yeah, exactly.
Well I learned from you that you have
a lot of sympathy for ass side as well.
Even though your, your sister passed away,
which is terrible. She didn't pass away.
She wasn't married.
But I can see that you also have sympathy
for the other side and you actually
are trying to,
you know,
communicate with us even though you went
through everything that you had to go
through on your end.
And I definitely learned that we can
learn to love your site as well or I could
learn till that bureau side as well.
I think this is the main 0.4 hour maybe
conflict that we did not hear from each
other. So I think it's important
to hear from each other,
not just keep your thoughts and ideas
inside your head and don't try to Aventis
box,
just tried to open it.
We want really similar things. Um, yeah.
And it's sort of, you feel like
you know, my friends from back.
And so the realization that we do
have the same sort of language,
not,
not in like the language that we speak,
but in our body language and the things
that interest us in the future that we
hold for ourselves and for families.
Like there are no sides.
Like I can't draw a line
and say, okay, I'm like
these people or with these people,
hey guys,
this is Jason and this is John.
And just want to say thank
you so much for watching.
I really special episode of Middle Ground.
Uh,
we love this series because it's an
opportunity now more than ever to create
great dialogue and create radical.
Yes.
Bothy uh,
this was a challenge,
but also a privilege to get to go to
Jerusalem to film this dialogue around a
subject that is very
tricky and very difficult,
but we loved having the challenge.
Totally.
You want to say a huge shout out
to youtube and created for change,
which gave us the resources
and the support to do this.
And we'd love to hear your thoughts.
Let us know what you thought about the
episode and the various perspectives and
the comments below,
and also let us know what
other suggestions for a
middle ground and you have.
We want to do more episodes
bigger and even better.
Yeah. And as always, please
be sure to click, subscribe
and follow us on Instagram.
I see you guys later.